now I'm finally gonna actually film
somebody walking in studio film I know
but I never filmed the people coming and
I'm in my body Chael Sonnen is here here
what up dudes good to see you man yeah
what's going on I mean everything
everything's going on it seems like it
you I you've managed to do very well in
Bellator you left the UFC or how many
years ago I don't know 13 okay I'd in
there and they're using a lot of
fighters at four than you have seen
you've had some good you you're on a to
fight win streak and you're fighting
fate or Emelianenko who is like the most
feared heavyweight probably in MMA
history I think that's right yeah I
think he's a talented guy I got I got no
problem with fate or uh he's not as
tough as me and I think that toughness
outweighs talent but I can't prove it
but I'm gonna find out on October 13
thank you for bringing that up by the
way right that's true that's right yeah
but he tells a master promoter to like
you you really are you were this close
to being the light heavyweight champion
in the UFC I mean John Jones broke his
toe and literally if that had just gone
a few more seconds he would not have
been able to come out and fight in the
second round yeah yeah yeah I almost won
the title against Anderson - I know I
I'd like to spread it around you know
I've blown it a couple of times you
can't just put it on one guy but that
John thing would have been a little
Fugazi though I mean I would have known
you know that wasn't much of a way to
win a champion if you still would have
fought as the champion and had to give
him a shot that's right you are right I
would have officially been been champion
though that's true it would have been a
little Fugazi yeah are you surprised
that like it seems like hardcore MMA
fans get really upset when the pro
wrestling style stunts really really
work because every time like the most
exciting sort of moments that draw in
the mainstream to MMA not for hardcore
fans I'm sure but the moments that draw
in the mainstream are those pro
wrestling moments it's when brock lesnar
runs into a cage unexpected it's the
whole build-up that you had with
anderson silva like all of that is pro
wrestling and it seems like it really
bugs the hardcore MMA guys that that's
even involved in the sport yeah and
there's enough to spread around right I
mean the hardcore fan has no idea why he
likes it he thinks he does but he
doesn't even know it's up to the
performer to it to invoke that emotion
and drama men and
ultimately the WWE is a big joke I mean
that sucks oh we hate being compared to
it - you think you suck I hate being
compared to it because it's such a
circus but the other side of it is ok
let's go more advanced let's not use the
insult of the clown show that is the
World Wrestling Entertainment let's just
use the reality of Hollywood every
single thing you see there is scripted -
but for some reason we don't call it
Hollywood because those actors are good
enough performers to drag us in but yes
some guys are reading scripts and
there's promos the only time you need to
preserve the integrity of the sport is
when the door shuts and as long as it's
a pure competition it doesn't matter
what goes on outside of it and you have
all these fans if I can finish this
point these fans that will tell you how
this guy talked his way into that or
this guy talked his way that none of
those fans have ever watched the show on
mute even they don't understand how much
they love the talking and the commentary
they just like to be the smart guy in
the room that can point it out and go oh
my gosh that's a promo that's an angle
they're trying to sell tickets what yes
stupid they are trying to sell the guy
always thinks he's the smartest guy in
the room when he can see the magician
moving his hands that you're not the
smartest guy you're just annoying we'd
have to make you one sorry to have to
make you want to watch the fight you are
amazing at that because people wanted to
see you fight because you like you were
they don't like you they buy a ticket to
either see you win or their lion ticket
to see you get your ass McGregor people
want to see him fight call becoming
Tunisian now is getting to that point of
people want to see him fight cuz he
talks so much when did you decide WWE
sucked because you know a lot of your
promos that you've done are based on WWE
WWF promos and I wouldn't agree with
that I've heard those comparisons I
don't know how strongly I would disagree
there but I don't know that I would
fully agree there seems to be something
when a performer is reading lines that
it then gets compared to WWE well why
don't you compare it to Hollywood that's
the same thing Will Smith and Johnny
Depp are do but don't you have lines
that line for line are the same as like
Billy Graham and people like that I I
have used that stuff I write that's not
much to those guys yes but again I could
go back to Hollywood and tell you where
Billy Graham got it and he got it from
some movie that he saw me those were the
best characters to grab I guess the
point I'm trying to make is is any time
there is a scripted promo and a line the
fan will be greatly resistant to that
but they're not in Hollywood then they
always dumb us down to the clown show
that Vince is put
so why did you decide that Vince's show
was a clown show well I mean look it's
what it is of those guys were skilled
performers they would be in Hollywood
there's a reason they make a hundred
grand a year instead of ten million a
year right I mean this is just the
reality of it and the same thing goes
with us fighters we're doing the best
that we can with some of these promos
and if we were better at it we want to
be having to go and trade punches and
kicks with some guy half naked we're all
just wearing a mouthpiece and it's just
the reality of it you can insult to us
to get compared to WWE we don't like so
you think it's a major downgrade that
Ronda Rousey is in WWE I think it was a
really good move for Ronnie to go to WWE
but I mean she's another one she's
another one the whole thing was smoking
mirrors I mean if you'll remember back
it was four years ago there was talk she
could beat Floyd Mayweather and people
were trying sports rights believing it
although she got a hold of my still
thing she'd beat him however getting in
there getting in there would be a hard
time because Amanda kind of she goes in
high for a takedown and I think Floyd
would be able to combat that yes and
that's meant to be fun that's not an
insult to her what I'm saying is that's
where she belongs
what about Brock I mean Brock's is you
know does stuff in WWE - he's there
champ yeah yeah I know what about Brock
Brock sucks but what are you are kiva
know Ryland your opinion yeah Brock's a
tremendous draw he's a
once-in-a-lifetime attraction but he's a
fighter it's not good well I just think
it's an athlete in whole you got to look
at his career a little bit closer you
know he and I were the same year and
called a dress and Brock was very
effective he was an undefeated national
champion now the other side of that coin
he was 60 pounds heavier than the guys
that he was wrestling he was 60 pounds
heavier the guy he had for the national
championship I could tell you if I had
even 6 pounds on a guy he couldn't make
it into overtime with me 60 pounds it's
relevant to it he still got his hand
raised he still found a way to do it I'm
not I'm not trying to insult Brock as
much as just to say there's a place for
everybody and that guy is a legitimate
attraction he did say sucks yeah yeah
what I'm saying as far as an attraction
goes the WWE was a really good fit well
Brock the thing about Brock is I have a
weird feeling I sometimes I like him
sometimes I don't he did be Frank Mir he
did beat mark hunt which he just kind of
laid on him he still beat mark hunt but
then you know he loses to Kane and
Alistair Overeem so I think he's kind of
50/50 whether he's gonna win or not I I
didn't like the Cormier promo as much
I'd rather see Cormier fight other
people than him but I get like for Mia
wants to fight who who would you throw
in there
I know I'd rather see Curtis blades get
a shot to be on really yeah I would
enjoy that fight really I would enjoy
that fight more than him in bra Kia but
you know that like they do it if I was
him I would a hundred percent do bra I
think you're bluffing I really mean that
I think if I told you that the brach was
gonna fight Curtis blades tomorrow
versus the reaction if I said Brock was
gonna fight Cormier tomorrow I think
you'd be more oh no no no no I mean I
mean Curtis played against Cory yeah I
would rather see no I really wouldn't I
don't care about Brock fighting really I
don't care I respect the fact that he
won but I don't care him as much about
him fighting I really don't I mean I
just buy into the attraction really no
it is an attraction it sells a lot but I
would rather watch a lot of other guys
like I was happy to see in gandu fight
for the title and most other public
doesn't know in gone oh you know I don't
really care that much about Brock but I
will watch and Curtis is good for sure
yeah as far as as far as a draw and
created emotion that surprises me yeah
now you're going up to heavyweight to
fight phaidor right yep wieszczyk we saw
the way you were middleweight and then
you're light heavyweight and then you
know that's a tremendous jump yeah you
know I tell you what when I started this
sport uh that's what we did I had my
fifth or sixth fight before I even saw
scale we didn't know anything about and
then they came up with the weight
classes which is a lot better for the
sport but I've knit but I was still the
old school mentality I never cared I
never cared about the weight classes or
are you ready or how much time you I
don't know anything about that man if
you want to fight and he wants to fight
you got to go fight like so you don't
even need all this time and and you just
want it you're ready to fight whoever
whenever whoever whatever yeah they
could change it I mean I'm expecting it
to be fatal and I don't know the fate or
ever pulling out of fights but if he did
I will still be at the Nassau Coliseum
on October 13 why was fate or never able
to get his deal done with UFC I mean I
know for a while Dana really wasn't in
my hand people around him is that right
yeah yeah that's my understanding I only
have Dana's a view of it I think he came
on and shared it with you at some point
but at any rate
Dana just said they really want to do a
KO promote they were forcing themselves
to not only give fate or deal but then
the management the team all needed a
deal and Dana's going I there's you you
don't offer anything how would even
pretend matakohe promote that's more the
boxing model they just couldn't get it
done yeah he did he just wasn't
interested in doing that but it wasn't
fatal himself I think it was the people
it sucks the people around him yeah
seems like a lot of money left on the
table it was yeah
he was a little older by then too you
know what I mean he's still just raw
he's still a huge man but he was a
little bit it wasn't like you know say
ten years earlier pie would have been
more tempting and it's hard to know if
there was money left on him I'm fade or
fade ores cleaned up everywhere he goes
he has right yes that's true yeah yeah
you guys are gonna make a lot of money
for this fight so yeah I'm not sure the
way that would work now there would be a
pay-per-view structure and some other
stuff whereas Coker will come up front
and just go look here's what your
participation is I hear your point on
that I'm just saying that I don't think
we need to shed a tear for fate oh I
think he did and they can make good
deals but he retired and then he comes
back I guess it's hard to walk away man
it's like when you just like you talked
about Chuck fighting again fighting I
guess Tito is the rumor I think when
you're really good at something and
that's what you do it probably is
difficult to walk away yeah you know is
it hard I mean as an athlete to go like
[ __ ] man I don't want to stop doing this
yep it is right because it's a different
form of commodity you know it's not just
the money but those cheers and that Fame
and that attention you know Rosie
O'Donnell said it best when she said
Fame as a drug but it is you know to
walk into those arenas to have people
with your t-shirts and holding holding
up your names and signs you can't get
that commodity anywhere else and right
you you know you just simply can't and
as fighters our careers all doing the
same which is face down and embarrassed
but until you're at that point you
usually go out there so there was then
there was no part of you after you were
gone from the UFC that was like you know
what that's a career I'm done yes that I
did for sure and I was very happy for
about two weeks and then I was bored
bored as could be didn't know what to do
with my time didn't know what to do with
my skills that I had you know I like
going to the gym that's how I saw the
guys a very close relationship with my
coaches you know that was just how I saw
him so I came back but I wouldn't want
to leave anything on the table I did
that with my amateur wrestling career
I've always wondered what if I would
have gone one more cycle could have I
made the Olympic team could have I've
been an Olympic champion I'll never know
cuz I walked away he's that how guys get
hurt too I get but you can get hurt at
any point in the sport you can get hurt
her first fight but is that what happens
sometimes like Ali came back and he
fought and you're certainly not in that
category of having been damaged but like
they just want one more fight and all of
a sudden something really dangerous
happens yeah and Ali's spoke on that
yeah he said you know yeah I let my mind
go in there and get get my ass kicked or
something along those lines I was gonna
give you the exact quote I lost place of
it but I think there's a lot of truth to
that fighters go out there too many
times we're seeing Chuck go through it
right now
right Chuck Chuck wasn't very good when
he left and that was seven years ago and
you don't get better at something by not
doing it but I can convince yourself
that you have gotten better right Chuck
doesn't look at it as I've been sitting
on my ass for seven years deteriorating
he looks at it is I am undefeated in the
land resting I'm giving my body a break
right gave my body break the guys aren't
as good today as they were back then you
sell yourself these things and it's not
to teach Chuck it's a reality that we
all go through no matter how many times
we get proven that that analogy doesn't
work we still subscribe to it so you
will watch fighters now and kind of fall
into that trap of like oh I mean these
guys are good but nothing compared to
the guys that I was in there with yeah
for sure well I see myself do that a
little bit but it's really not true
right I see people make this argument
all the time with basketball that Jordan
was the best ever
or with tennis about McEnroe ins that
guys hold on you're not actually
complimenting Michael Jordan at all
you're insulting the sport of basketball
you're saying the sport has not grown
since 1989 you're insulting the entire
sport I mean it's basic biology things
either evolve or they become extinct
yeah I guess that's true and tend to say
that we're done we figured out who the
best of all time is 20-30 years ago
however long ago was he says that we're
done with the sport right you know I
gotta ask you something you look very
nice today did you get a haircut I mean
it's it's quaffed
really you know I've gotten a haircut
I've done shaving I kinda like I'm more
than aware of who you are but I'm not
positive we met before my eyes coming up
here today he goes yeah Sam Roberts he's
my guy yeah he's good he's got an afro
uh-huh
no no he's got a pert you look like a
real gentleman you look very nice I
really appreciate that you were coming
in and you always look great so I was
like you know what let me make sure that
I look proper for chance not sure you
know yeah exactly nice collar incidents
you brought up Colby earlier Colby
coming that's right and he's from Oregon
and I know he looks up to you that's
right you go thank you for that but you
guys had him in here we did nice guy
like you know it's funny I like Jim no
he doesn't like me I like to Colby I had
a really good time with him he was funny
and then when you're sitting next to
somebody you can pick up their energy
and I'm like he's a nice dude he's just
he's a promotion guy and he's smart he
wants to his name to be out there he
wants to fight Woodley and this before
the fight with RDA may I guess why he
doesn't like you before you tell me yes
can I guess sure is it because
Matt Serra did you were you guilty by
association no it was because we had the
next week we had Colby booked to be on
UFC unfilter two days later it was just
the schedule three weeks out we had him
booked and then our producer booked
tomorrow Oman in studio because in
studio guests are harder to get in New
York these guys were in Vegas or they're
in camp in Florida whatever the foot
it's hard to do we take guys in studio
so we figured hey Colby likes to talk
[ __ ] and promote komaru spawn as well
turn and then all of a sudden he's in
with us and Colby's on the phone and he
feels like we are setting him up because
Matt wasn't there that day but it was
pre book by weeks and so he goes out and
goes uh Jim Norton's a loser I'll never
do his podcast again like I set up he
said you're a nerd a nerd he's not wrong
but I still like him I still think he's
fun to watch I was honored to be lumped
in with you he mentioned a whole lot of
people he doesn't like something I'm in
a good company but it was like we didn't
set him up that kind of annoyed me I
didn't set you up dude it's like come on
you you like to promote you like to I
even asked him when he was in here I'm
like it doesn't help you to go out and
have this kind of stuff so you're not
obsessed with the fight he goes yeah a
lot of guys obsess on the fight I don't
obsess on the fight I'm thinking of all
this other stuff so I didn't think it'd
be a big deal at all him and komaru
talking who gives a [ __ ] he's promoting
for RTA but he's already trained so it's
like you know so he got mad at me
thought I set him up but he was never
set up sure I see your intentions there
I mean I I fully get what you do that
I'm not even booked at my producer I
will share with you as a fighter when we
do in it but that situation it feels
like a setup absolutely yeah I could see
him being annoying about it but it was
like a he was booked three weeks out and
then I asked Chris my producer I'm like
I don't booked this show the UFC does
and Chris goes well I actually booked
tomorrow because they said he's gonna be
in New York do you want him they offered
him and he took him but it wasn't like
Jim Norton said him are perfect like
here yeah but I still like called me I
don't care if he hates me he's fun to
watch he's an Iron Man I don't care III
still want to see him fight I'm a creep
but I do want to see I do want to see
him fight tyron woodley
so fellas you were mentioning that I'm
fighting phaidor Friday that's right
that way and Ticketmaster yeah
bellator.com
what else were we talking about I also
want to talk to you about the fact that
you are involved in real estate and
that's one of my favorite things if you
have you have something a lot of guys
don't it's like you could make
a lot of money without fighting if you
wanted to you might have other interests
that's nice to say but I do have other
interests yeah you know politics are my
biggest passion I've never seen a I've
never seen a football game in my life
I've never seen a basketball game my
uncle went to two NBA titles I've never
seen a basketball game it drives him
crazy
I'm just play for its guy he wanted so
he was a 68 Tokyo I apologized 64 Tokyo
Olympic champion 165 title for the
Celtics and then I don't know where he
got his next title well I might have
even won three NBA championships I know
I went to it but he might have won what
is his last name Sonnen Mel counts Mel
counts yeah but you just don't care
sports are not your thing I was just not
into sports I wish that I was I like I
have friends that are big sports guys
and they're just passionate about I
guess where I went to this I was telling
you yeah I do have some other interests
that they might even surprise you but
they're not they're not really sports
related but we talked on your podcast
one so you do a great podcast yeah um it
was about the whole banking scandal and
you had a pretty good explanation of cuz
like how come nobody went to jail and
what's the banking scandal with a whole
the whole thing with the mortgages and
all that stuff a few years ago Oh like
why people didn't go to jail for that
you pointed out that it was hard to find
people accountable because so much it
was just done on the phone you know one
guy calls and says hey do that and it's
not like you're not trading name
volatile it was very shady the way they
did if you if you see the big short was
the rehab yeah it was one was an
excellent movie but to a Christian Bale
as well it was an excellent movie but it
was so incredibly accurate and I was in
the industry at that time and yes it was
the banks that were just a voice over
the phone that were then telling the
little guys how to do it if you send it
to us and the paperwork says this we can
patch the deal through they were doing
that all day long and you could never
track it back to them and the banks
didn't the government didn't even want
to look into the banks they just went
after the mortgage brokers and the
Realtors and and those guys had fault to
those guys I heard on their hands but
there still is an example that the bank
is the boss and when the boss is telling
you over the phone do it this way and
you do it that way I think he needs to
probably be looked at as well but
there's no recording of that he's never
written it down and you don't even know
his name
you always know in a corporate structure
like when you're emailing with somebody
and they either call you or ask you to
come talk to him that's because they
don't want a paper trail because all the
emails get saved but you can still call
somebody or talk to somebody
face-to-face and that's Dennis you wanna
say yeah I don't
I don't remember having that
conversation yeah and that's really how
it went you know you're on a bank the
banks in Maryland the banks in Chicago
the banks in New York we're out in
Portland Oregon and you know the markets
going upside down and these guys are
walking away so I don't anything about
it
so now you probably never got screwed
financially because you're one of the
guys who knows how to look at your
finances you know you don't know what to
look for so at least that's one
advantages they probably couldn't screw
with your money like you know everyone
loses money when they get rich and they
have an accountant take care of it they
don't oh yeah yeah just paid yeah that's
one of those things yeah you kind of got
to do that yourself
I do have an accountant but yeah you got
to be involved in that you can see where
all of that stuff is going and then it's
tough to over time you you trust a guy
you still got to be involved you take a
look at it yeah I don't sign up a power
of attorney that and it had to sign
every check and if you don't fully
understand it you better fake like you
understand it you know right you can you
got to rattle the cage a few times just
to make them think you're paying
attention but I mean that is just the
reality that's a little sign of business
it isn't in the books but it's it's the
truth guys who lose every three
something yeah people paid they let the
manager do everything the matter doesn't
pay taxes he takes loans out of it he
[ __ ] makes investments I don't know
about it loses money you know just sign
over power of attorney and it's just
like your your hands off and it's crazy
disaster alter yeah once a year you're
not calling up your team and you're
yelling even if you got to make it up if
you're not doing that you're not doing
good business you got to call up and
give them some [ __ ] so they know that
you're on you're on it and you're you're
looking at it yep even if they go hey
you got this all wrong okay we'll keep
telling me but I've done my part here
yeah you called and you've yelled a
little bit how did you feel about your
exit from UFC was it fair unfair my well
it was it was by my choice so yeah so
yeah
I felt fine about it I mean I missed the
UFC UFC was great but I miss Bellator
too I haven't got a fight since January
I wish I was fighting tonight I love it
it's it's a seductive event I worked
really hard in the gym to go off and
show it off and I don't ever know you
know phaidor is a tough son [ __ ] I know
I can beat him but I know he can beat me
too mm-hmm I want I don't ever fight
guys that I that I know that's what a
bully does I'd I never know and I
enjoyed that rush I enjoy that you know
you got a 50-50 chance those are very
good odds
what am I getting popped for drugs like
you sometimes people go like sometimes
it's people claim it to [ __ ] up on the
test parts people go no I [ __ ] up I
did this yeah I got caught whatever like
when you get popped is
one of those like how the hell does this
happen or [ __ ] yeah I did well so I'll
speak for myself yeah for me it was how
did this happen because I thought I
could get away with it and he said well
they found this then they found this and
they found this in your system it was
silent on my end because I was waiting
to so did they find this in this so wait
so okay so it's early three against
seven I came out ahead but I still got
to go deal with these three and that was
really that was really the situation but
you know the I will tell you when I went
through it is a little bit tough like
just by example I've never taken a
steroid in my life I've never even been
accused of them but when you pop for now
what they're calling peds
performance-enhancing drugs look
performance at enhancing or positive
terms so how all of a sudden these came
relevant on a list I really don't know
but this is the place we're at and if
you get popped it steroids that's right
the public understand his favors and I
just steered into it I mean I was making
t-shirts with syringes because I found
that there was there was really no
advantage to explaining and there wasn't
a tremendous downside for for being
guilty which was a surprise and I don't
say that to skate anything I did but
when I lived through it I thought okay
my life as I know it and this business
is over but surprisingly the the public
good they don't really care yeah it
seems like if people want to pay to see
you fight or pay to hear you talk or
whatever they're still gonna do it right
like the like getting getting popped for
whatever is not gonna stop them if Jon
Jones gets announced for fighting again
Brock Lesnar's fighting again like
people want to just see these guys fight
the public doesn't care as much about
the fact that Brock did some fighters do
John is different do you believe John
John is saying that he had a tainted
supplement no that that's a very tough
story I mean I know I know that John was
using by looking at him you know we all
know our own he look he could look at me
and knew who knew what I was taking we
all know our own so no I don't think
that the tainted supplement theory will
work but I also don't know what his
punishment will be look he's got a four
year max he's got a floor of two years
and if you look at president-- I think
he's only gonna look at that two years I
think we'll see him back next summer and
when I look at someone like Junior dos
Santos and they he was
actually acquitted they said that but
there was a some pharmaceutical I guess
processing company or whatever in Brazil
it was three fighters that got popped
but he really didn't do it yeah that's
got to be a nice relief yeah he and
little nog both went down on that
together I think they're teammates I
know there used to be but they pull and
Anderson they all go down on the on the
same charge and they all got cleared
Keith Anderson get cleared he did
because they ruled that it was a a
tainted supplement and what that term
means is just he took a supplement by
example I'm drinking a water right now
there's something goofy in the water I
drink it I just had no thought I was
well I had no knowledge right and that's
a really tough test fans hear that and
they get irritating go tainted
supplement I've heard that one before
but now they're it's a really stringent
to actually come to that conclusion and
they did it they spent the money and
they did I mean I'm talking about who
sada the testing organization did it the
ones that are trying to persecute him
the ones who are if they rule him
innocent are likely gonna find themself
in a lawsuit they did it and they still
came out and go guys we got this wrong
yeah dicin he didn't do he deserves that
to be said about him yeah I was guilty
before he was last time but now they
caught him but he was clear on this one
I interviewed him about it here I'm
talking about he was very very like just
to be accused falsely of that is is just
it's horrible the stuff that you got
popped for the what type of performance
enhancers were they if not steroids like
now that you can explain it without
being in a defensive position yeah well
so here's the thing about that is all
medication has to enhance you right
that's the first thing the FDA makes you
prove and III was always stuck on this
when I would be before commissions and
they asked me have you ever taken
anything to enhance your performance and
I'm under oath I'm going guys in my life
I've never taken anything unless I
thought it would enhance my performance
that's all I'm looking to take I've
never taken a drug I never had a drop of
alcohol but if it's going to make me
better and it's legal I'm in and that
used to be the test I came through the
NCAA we had to take classes on what you
could take look if it was a legal
prescription from a doctor it was fair
game that used to be the rule in the
sport somewhere they changed that rule
and here we are all said I was in the
hot seat so that's kind of win it that's
kind of what happened for me but yeah I
was taking it purely for enhancement of
my
formitz I was not I've never gone to a
doctor I said doc I feel great can you
bring me down Yeah right
I believe that be malpractice if he said
yes is one of those things where they
figure it's getting to put where guys
are so good and they're so strong and
this point it's a somebody's gonna get
killed and I think that's what they're
worried about is that somebody is that
like crooked doctors right I mean I mean
guys find doctors that are just write
scripts for anything yep and so and then
it becomes when you do have a legit
prescription you kind of getting lumped
into all the guys that have wacky
doctors yep you're talking about doctor
shopping yep we're ya around and you and
we're seeing that on higher levels now
with this big opioid crisis where guys
are going over to this dock and it's
control but they just go to this dock
too and they get multiple scripts and
they figure out how to do it but um and
that can be a problem but as far as the
way the rules worked yeah it was it was
really tough we have a totally different
understanding of them now I was the
first guy ever tested at a competition
back prior to me testing hot it was just
you on fight night you got to show up
clean on fight night so when they
changed some of the rules without
telling me but it was a tough spot yeah
cuz guys who are used to doing it a
certain way oh you have to have younger
fighters it might be a little easier for
because they've kind of had to come into
these rules but once you started stepped
in it seemed like it was harder for for
guys who had been doing things a certain
way now all of a sudden to have to stop
doing there was just a learning curve I
mean the sports bettor where it is now
it's it's better getting rid of guys
that were doing what I was doing I'm not
sitting here trying to give you guys a
defense I'm trying to speak candidly on
it I was guilty and they found me guilty
but what I'm saying is if you change the
rules it is kind of important that you
let people know you change the speed
sign through town that's been there for
twenty years and you do it in the dark
of night right the next morning that's a
little unfair to ticket a guy instead of
letting him know we have now changed the
world's okay well if you changed the
rules you know that we got operate
within these rules right I was I was
completely within the rules the way they
used to be
I understand so like to me one of my
favorite things he ever did was the bill
to that Anderson Silva fight I still
think that in terms of building towards
a fight specifically anywhere in MMA
it's tough to imagine a fight that had a
better bill the better story and I like
the theatrics of everything obviously
how did you and him coexist
after because that wasn't sort of a
cooperative bill that was you
saying I'm going to turn whether people
think this is a big money fight or not
I'm going to turn this into a massive
event and you did yeah yeah he was tough
you know and Anderson does not
understand it and there are guys in this
life and you guys all know him too that
have a whole bunch of money and so they
think they're really smart cuz a lot of
times intelligence and money go hand in
hand he's a dumb-dumb whole bunch of
money it's really hard to bring him
along and get him to see what we were
doing here and it has it has afterwards
too I thought well you know what he beat
me fair and square we're gonna shake
hands and walk away and it's hard to do
with him if there's a real arrogant
attitude that you're met with there and
there's an intelligence that he has and
there's a it's like Andersen me you
don't have any of those things you're a
dumb dumb cage fighter just like me
right so let's just take our t-shirts
off and do this thing one more time
right Anderson no but you got in his
head so bad that second flight where you
tried the spinning backfist and fell and
he I guess put in a chair he won the
fight he cried he brought his kids into
the occasion was crying like beating you
meant so much to like he was viewer in
his head right well that was one reason
talking about Brazilian kids you know
eating mud and and doing all that right
watch yep and and and after that first
fight which was I guess it was a
triangle I guess then with the v it was
if Ezra and you you beat him four and a
half rounds of that fight he knew it and
if you had just stayed away in that
fight you would have won but you didn't
which was amazing to me the yeah stay
well thank you for saying that yeah I've
got three ten eight rounds in my whole
life and they're all against him and
yeah I had his number he what just
wasn't a very hard fight for me but he
sure was hard to beat for me right he
had his hand raised both times and it
was it was fair and square so I don't
really have an animosity there but I
think the question was how do we we
coexisted sense and yeah and more about
does he have an animosity because I know
that you know what you're doing yeah
he's still very frustrating for me you
know it is very frustrating but the
sport in the industry as a whole learned
a lot from that I mean I I definitely
changed the industry the way this sport
is promoted the way that the guys will
handle themselves building and leading
up to fights and that could be for
better or worse I'll let the audience
decide but but without question I
changed it I do enjoy when when fighters
started looking at that model and trying
to repeat it but so many of them are so
bad at talking it was almost like what
you doing man don't don't worry about
sure don't worry about attempting that
just fight and that's where it comes
back to the WWE comparison right right
they're not very good at it either and
we don't get equated to say the
Hollywood model worse look yeah they're
still playing characters and reading
scripts it's it's it's not real in
Hollywood either right but you don't
have any desire to go to WWE or did you
at some point discuss it way back in my
life I was twenty years old and I was
between my sophomore and junior year in
college and I went out to something
called the power plant which was owned
by WCW sure remember that terseness
organization and of everybody that tried
out only me and another guy were invited
to come back but I was gonna finish
college I two years left and then I
thought I was gonna pursue that or at
least keep that an option and WCW ended
up going out of business and I never
looked back I went to the UFC mmm
yeah it's uh you know the called the
Covington is a guy wonder because he
actually broke the wall and said hey I'm
just doing a character to sell fight and
to me I didn't know why he did I'll you
never did that like you were almost
willing to say because I I know you and
I know you're a nice guy there's a term
and its core it's called being afraid of
the heat like like wanting to tell
people hey this is just a roll but you
never really did that no no gracious
when you lost like you didn't you didn't
turn you know you okay Anderson
but he never for a champion was afraid
of the heat never afraid of the heat you
never seemed to mind walking around
having people wonder is that who this
guy is all the time yeah you didn't seem
to do you think it's bad to break the
fourth wall does it hurt the does it
hurt what he's doing or anybody who does
it Oh
overall I think that it is and I never
would have broke it either I would have
just gone around with everybody hating
me and getting daily death threats and
secretly laughing about I do believe
that is the best way that the magician
takes it takes it to the grave but you
know the sport grew right right around
that time when I was doing all the crazy
stuff I had a microphone so many times
I'm not that good of an actor I can give
you a few good lines I can keep a
straight face for a little bit I can
piss off a whole bunch of people but I
can't do it as many hours of a day as
they started expecting me to do it so
that's that's why I was forced to drop
it Colby is doing something a little bit
different where he is coming out and
entertaining and so many guys will wait
for the UFC to come in and bring them
opportunities like this one or two set
up cameras Kobe's the first guy ever to
go hire his own camera crew he
his own production crew and start
marketing and promoting himself in his
own way took him all the way to a world
championship fight his skills took him
to a world championship but he's gonna
be another one the same as I gave myself
credit a moment ago for changing the
sport and the way that things are
promoted and I did Kobe is also offering
something very new and innovated by
simply bringing in his own production
crews and created in his own channels
and going out there what let's see where
it goes but I do believe he's get also
gonna change the sport yeah people will
watch it just to see him get his ass
kicked I mean it's it's crazy to say
that like what you want I don't really
love Connor but I'll watch him fight
because I even want to see he's always
beating up guys I like but I'll still
watch him because I would love to see
somebody beat him you know so I will
watch those fights yeah you know you
watch the people you hate too
yeah yeah I watch Connor for some of
that and a lot of it i watch to be
entertained but you know there's all the
people that like to say that they don't
like to talk and all of this stuff in
this sport which those guys will never
make a dollar in this business right but
but they love to come out of be the
biggest experts every single one of them
when Connor fights they hush everyone
down in their living room and then turn
the volume up so they can hear his
post-fight speech so those very same
people that say they don't like it they
love it they just have that lack of
awareness about themselves yeah and they
want to sell like you said they want to
sound like they're they're more informed
people they go I don't like all that but
if it's genuine I like it you know I
mean I with you it's 100% genuine with
Connor I feel like it's genuine like I
don't look at Connor and go he's full of
[ __ ] like right that guy's talking like
that's that's who this guy is you can
always tell when people are acting and
you're like you're not an actor man like
I can see that you're a fighter you're
great at this but I don't want to see
you act
it's cringe-worthy it when they do yeah
when they think they fool year the guys
got the great line and he drops the line
it looks like the cat that ate the
canary and then the interview asks him a
follow-up question huh and he wasn't
expecting a follow-up question he played
it through and practice it in the mirror
he never anticipated follow-up question
either drop the mic and walk out or
rehearse a follow-up yeah because he's
doing that thing that you talked about
where it's like do you just read in a
script you're not right this isn't
coming off your head it's not coming off
your head yeah and then you won't have
helped right the commentators won't
won't help you yeah they caught yourself
you don't really have a tag-team partner
like you do when you're when you're with
Vince so yeah you got it you got to be a
chess player you got to be two or three
steps because you're really you're
putting yourselves over sure there's not
somebody out you're creating a story and
getting that out direct
the audience in a cooperative yeah yeah
that's right
josée aldo tried doing that when he was
gonna fight conor he got like a little
eat you got out of his thing and it just
didn't feel right I'm like you're the
quiet guy be the quiet guy like that's
we are it didn't seem right when he was
trying to taunt him back
sure and guys in our sport right now are
also trapped in a misconception if I
have to talk trash I've got to talk
trash that's what Dana White loves
that's what Scott Coker loves now you
don't have to talk trash you just have
to talk right and if they ask you at the
end of a fight who do you want next and
you say I don't care I know what your
message is your message just to sound
like a tough guy that's willing to fight
anybody but it's not what you said you
said you don't care right if I'm a fan
and you don't care how can I write you
have to have an answer you must have an
answer at all times whatever it is but
you've got to say something we're not
holding a camera no Micra I had it at
press conferences with guys I have set
record numbers for press conferences I
have sold-out press conferences they've
been on free TV they stream live and
have done record numbers some prick is
always sitting up there across from me
that goes I don't even know why we're
talking I'm just here to fight I'm not
here to talk well that's not true you're
at a press conference to talk you know
I've seen people flown in some from
Brazil some from Russia from across the
world I couldn't imagine the journeys
they've come on to sit at a press
conference in their nights I've seen
females do it at nice dresses or guys
try to nice suits and go I don't want to
talk that's not what I do
next question and we won't come back to
you right no we also won't cut this up
we also won't make this go viral in the
internet we also won't see you on
SportsCenter tonight but fair enough we
know where you stand
that's one of those things when you call
a guy out even if it's a guy you're not
gonna get normally that guy has to
respond so that pushes it one step
forward and then you can respond to him
and it may work or it may not work I
mean al Iaquinta everyone always talks
about because he's [ __ ] goes on
Twitter and just blast people so they
kind of have to respond it gets people
interested gets people interested and
people have to be interested to buy
ticket he's great a like when it gets a
bad rap
al I love when he's awesome that's true
and he is mad that's true and he does
have a chip on yeah that's true that's
awesome let's turn that up let's not
turn him away let's turn that guy up
when they lose personnel and when they
ask him to fight hippy he stepped in on
one day's notice he was been trained of
a Paul Felder who's a [ __ ] brawl
and even though he lost a Habib I mean
he when he stepped up and other guys
trying that fight down that's that's
what Jo was talking about in your
fighter be ready to fight whoever
whenever right yeah
so do you look at the fate or fight that
you have coming up and go like okay I
really don't need to [ __ ] on fate or
number one because I'm legitimately
respect him but number two this is a big
enough fight with two big enough names
that I don't have to convince you as to
why you should be interested in this
thing I do believe that we're gonna do
really great business that yeah right I
do believe that the place is gonna be
sold out we're gonna set record numbers
Scott Coker says the biggest fight in
UFC history other people saying it's the
the biggest fight of 2018 I appreciate
that in that flatters me my job is
something else which is to go in there
and fight him but it is very hard to
come out and get a banter going with him
I don't not like fade or I don't like
fade or I don't know fade or but neither
does anybody else and that does annoy me
a little bit you know it does annoy me
that he's on his way here from Russia
right now to do media to which he's not
gonna do he's gonna have an interpreter
that looks like Snow White talking about
don't be dwarf who was him but he came a
different time you know some of those
same problems I had with Anderson Silva
or that Chuck Liddell's going to go
through when that first off that fight
with Chuck and Tito's not gonna happen
second off if it happens which it's not
if it happens nobody's gonna watch it
the reason is Chuck is from a different
time he used to be when the punches and
kicks were enough the UFC was doing five
and six shows a year Bellator didn't
even exist Scott Coker hadn't stepped in
to the space yet if you could see two
guys locked in a cage together right was
enough but we are now living in the
entertainment era and it's a totally
different era there is 53 shows a year
in a 52 week calendar year by the UFC
Scott Coker is putting on 23 shows a
year which in a 52 week calendar year
means twice a month the punches and
kicks are not enough and we've still got
commentators that are locked in the
1990s that won't help a guy they'll turn
on the business before they'll help the
business they don't understand what
we're doing here now it's very
competitive and now you'd say why would
I watch this fight if two people don't
give a [ __ ] of that this is for casual
fans when I could when I can watch a guy
who's at least got me interested and
you're talking all week how do the
commentators not help the business will
have commentators that will go out when
guys are fighting and they will disclose
to the audience well he's only here
because he
a bunch of trash it's like first off
that's what we're doing okay and I find
it very ironic that a commentator whose
only job is to talk who's never had to
get off his biscuit and get in there and
risk it but it's making more money than
anybody else who actually has I find
that very off-putting and secondly just
operate within the confines of the truth
okay look at look at Coby Covington
truth
last time he stayed at a fighter hotel
he got enough street altercation with
former heavyweight champion for reishi
over doom where criminal charges were
pressed Kobe covered ends to go
everywhere with security in an armored
vehicle in his estate of private
location because of the death threats
made against him just tell the truth all
of those things are true and the
promoters writing a check for a reason
and it isn't actually because he thinks
somebody's going to get in a street
altercation with the baddest dude in the
world is Kobe Covington he's doing it
hoping that somebody's got the
intelligence God gave geese to come out
on a microphone and tell the story to
the world because it's captivating but
you still got these commentators that
want to talk about the setup behind a
jab followed by the right cross to the
leg kick - shut up man it's not what
we're doing that was in the 90s now
we're in the entertainment era and you
think that they're not servicing the
entertainment part of it as much and the
fact that these guys are out here you
know you kind of you're putting your
life out there and you're talking a lot
and then they're not going to address
that at all they're just gonna talk
about well they're not stuff you and I
talked about the pure mechanics of it
yeah they don't understand it they don't
understand that the times have changed
and they will again we're not gonna be
in the entertainment area forever right
we're gonna go back and then there's
gonna be your mega fights and there's
gonna be your fights that follow the
straight and hard right - you know we
just saw when Cormier versus Steve a
that was an amazing amazing event you
had two world champions locked in
together from two different weight
classes to guys with integrity with no
problems pillars of their community
those things only come along every so
often the rest of the time we're here to
entertain the integrity is preserved
when you lock the cage door it's not
professional wrestling where the guys
are working the the spots out together
and it who goes over but that's it for
right now
it will change yet again but when you've
got commentators that are stuck in the
90s that don't want to help the business
and they want to go pick up a paycheck
at the end of the night if they got to
change too